i try to picture myself here thinking
you know
i have nothing better to do with my time
that i would want to
manufacture indignation and drama and go
down to a statue or a monument of
somebody from 100 200 300 years ago that
did something significant
and take it down because at that time
you know
something was common that might be
offensive today it's like
you have you have some you have some
growing up to do man like like you have
some serious thinking to do about your
position in the world in your life but
i don't see that changing too much man
like i see more and more of that
happening i see more and more guys
transitioning
into that sphere like into that space
and it's really real tough to watch
i'm i'm more of the kind of like sit
back and let it burn sort of mentality
at this point
i know you mentioned that video that if
you didn't have kids you know be up in
the mountain doing that right now but
i just i just take care of my inner
circle and i just say all right look you
know
here's here's the facts as i see him you
hear hear the opinion of the mainstream
media hear the opinion of the school
system hear the opinion of
of teachers and your peers but don't be
sheep
don't be cheap you know rich it's um
i kind of did a you know a little rant
i guess on a video kind of half joking
just
pissed off of gavin newsom for what he's
been doing in california
and i kind of teased about running for
governor in that video i mean i got
so much support and i was like wow you
know it's almost i don't start
thinking like i remember a uh interview
by donald trump on oprah
years ago a couple few decades ago and
she had asked me he'd ever run the
president he said you know what
i really love what i do probably never
would ever run for president but if the
country got that bad then i'd maybe
consider it i remember that interview
and then i started thinking to myself
you know i would never want to be in
politics i'm not politically well-versed
um but seeing the people that are
running these countries
uh these states and cities i'm like [ __ ]
any idiot can do it obviously and then i
just kind of made that video about
running for governor california people
were like please aubry run please aubrey
run and i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm about 90
sure that i want to run in 2022 against
this guy
i mean we need more men real men
it's not these beta males haven't just
infiltrated our streets and
tearing down our statues they're in our
government oh yeah they don't
they have no backbone they have no balls
they have no conviction they're being
told what to do by the powers to be
behind the curtain and they're just
puppets and we need more men in there
like donald trump who doesn't give a
[ __ ] has his own money i'm a politician
who will actually what he's trying to do
is clean his drain the swamp and that's
why we have all these crybabies right
now
he's on to everybody and these leftist
behind the scenes
goons and elitists they're fighting back
and they're using their
this dumbed down social justice warriors
that have been growing up in the
participation trophy generation to do
their dirty work
yeah i i you know i wonder though you
know because i look at
i mean your president right now is
donald trump and he's about as alpha as
they come and he can't even get much
done
you know he's he's constantly stolen
well he's constantly fighting to
um you know to pass legislation law and
get things
you know moving in the right direction
but uh
i mean i did some lobbying a couple
years ago around 20 2013 and 2015 here
in ontario with queen's park with the
provincial government and i
i found i got nothing done and i had the
right approach the right agenda
i had the right argument to to prove
that the
legislation that the big banks were
trying to pass was going to be
harmful to the canadian consumer they
didn't want to hear it man they just
wanted to go with what would preserve
uh their seat in parliament and their
job
they don't really care about you know
the public in general all they care
about is themselves
and preserving their seat in that job as
long as possible in their retirement
everything else comes along with that so
i mean i mean it's a virtuous fight to
push
we got to get term limits that's that's
the the bottom line and we've had people
like
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer all these
guys here they've been in in uh
in government for decades now that's
crazy
it's just how do you how can you justify
that and these people come into politics
and they come out
multi mo and i'm talking
multi-millionaires
yeah how does that happen on your salary
right nobody puts this together like
obama's came in right obama was i think
he was worth maybe a million bucks
you know him and his wife if indeed
michelle is
his woman but
but uh yeah let's call her a woman yeah
yeah and then
they come out of this thing out of his
presidency like
net worth of over 40 million dollars you
know brand new house and that i think of
the hamptons or something i might have
how does that happen on a uh
presidential salary i know you have your
speaking gigs you know but
you don't make 40 million dollars on
public speaking so
you know you gotta you gotta ask
yourself where's all this money coming
from for these
elitists right and yeah i i don't know
man it's it's just so corrupt
and that's why we're seeing such
pushback right now
it's no it's no coincidence that all
this started happening in 2016
you know when donald trump was elected
president it's
connect the dots you know
everything's quiet with the status quo
with obama and
you know you know clinton back in the
day you know everything's okay nobody
sees the shade that's going on behind
closed doors it's a real evil but
when the evil gets confronted and then
somebody comes in that's not a career
politician that has seen this from the
outside
you know i get this all the time like
donald trump knew
jeffrey epstein yeah he did when he was
younger and lived
basically three doors down in west palm
back in the day
and now he's been to his house he's got
pictures with him but once i think
donald trump knew what he was into he
was gone
basically told him you're not welcome
here anymore he outed
epstein so donald trump has seen all
this corruption over his lifetime being
the billionaire he's been
and now he he's over it he's sick of
seeing what has happened to america
and he's fighting back against all these
guys and that's why we're seeing the
hissy fit
you